o hello my name is this calm founder
president of link and linguistic
instinct i speak ten languages ​​and
i even wrote a book on
how to learn language
grammar children simply
Listen children listen to very limited content
or content
but listen very
often and working at age 2
and when the child feels confident
when the child has learned many
words and phrases starts to speak you
can learn faster
learn better  that a child Ok ok
You
already know a lot of words
in your native language
you know how to read and you use the link system today
and in the link you can find a wide
variety of interesting materials
to listen to he was if you are a beginner
I always fixed
choosing materials from  short duration
materials does this
it takes listening many times and
saving
words and phrases to learn using
the functions  ntions functions of the Lica system
and if you are more advanced you can
choose the child but more
interesting and also listen light and
alphabet learn french and speak
words and
and when you feel confident then
you can speak with your territories
it is also possible to write and  thirds
corrected texts for our editors
you can meet the other members of
our International Community
and is Come to the link I'm waiting
looking forward to meeting you thank you very
much
the konectiva the attack Steve Kaufmann
take today but link Look the kiss the
tongue Steel Shade hours old  our
mass if I know I'm going to take a bath
here in this one even as a cadist
well I
go there
his
blood Ultimate chest
gave another one here plus this other link
tax system I call you from here but
then
link Jorginho link doesn't go there  at
his grandma that is
and you already came to play step link
Johnny and the Bus damn it doesn't poop
like that I saw there you have
a traffic aunt my jab  uti became a fan
bye those in downtown and shrimp direct
Instituto de Linguistics and Lake Iá
evaluate Nadia City
rzk
I went ratiche feedback in which that is the
minimum to illustrate in the music
in my sound box
are the light answer hesitate
Ezequiel Eta hesitate deck carioca
horrible  a net guy
here
must-visit grammar doesn't touch flux and
sushi noga and I'm boring okay I'm going there
finishes on this one from Gêmea and I can read it
I'll go back now now it was Bionic late
night Party is
today Israel Novaes phrase we
try
We
love u
I
show city e  mold the wife another
system link na link the Idiot long in the
place
interest ticket and this Leave It All
To Shine the thighs new to improve your
scientific evidence
and
activities and withdraw thousands and phrase is
this
system league and this
fashionable goat in is
lend me  4.1
and reload Wii it's fair if it comes
because it Hit you think it comes prepared
late
at today I was a lot of striker saipes
way boot on Av Érico climb
dramatic
A Iá cabrio roxinho truffle Bar  ros
Residence
in Kenya
iá iá do i the radio makes the commission will be
created to spend a little space and
oh hello the prince Carlos mano is that
beautiful of the language silence the link and
rub recents Farm a bye VW Gol
hamburgers children
the pyromaniac
best-seller diaper Mano gives  the
meeting of and falls on the fifth Go i-motion
rock in ditto
the machine of the asked Still Calm here the
ROM
Zéfiro da
skirt
I'm 12 years old fast base that never
comes back where your [ __ ]
the game is out to have known
Van Damme adults don't deny  Lena
goes to the fifth dance I'm going to
put
all I am
the link Perez and zero
interesting queue the high end of Figueira
Vieira level
1 where it sells to a rooster that they guarantee to
because the client is wanting to get involved
with emphasis for the
time
that  tell me Ester that this type
of Zefiro China aims at some bales of
grass and sport at the end and end of the
sphere day
ai
super no audio